I sort of interesting fact is that while
today programming is viewed as the
extremely male dominated field,
it was totally the opposite at the dawn
of computing.
All programmers of uh,
uh,
from the very beginning where women had,
and it was because this job was seen as
being beneath men.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so somehow in the interceding 30,
40,
50 years that's come Jack Gender
Dynamics has completely shifted around.
But what we're seeing now is that
sometimes it's the implicit biases that
we have,
which are holding back women and
minorities from entering the workforce
and,
uh,
either as data scientists or,
or as computer,
uh,
engineers and software engineers.
And we've seen a lot of research in this
area that's shown that there can be some
implicit biases that,
uh,
and how we judge people once we know
about,
uh,
their ne,
from their name,
their sort of their gender or their
race.
And what we do right when we assess the
people who were going to be working for
us is we are completely blind to these
things.
We actually strip away the name when we
consider people,
um,
applications.
We just look at how they perform on a
series of challenges that we give them
that really try to test their ability
to,
uh,
be a data scientist and test their
understanding of these kind of core
fundamental mathematical and programming
concepts.
And,
uh,
when we do that,
I think it actually becomes a much more
fair process,
um,
and it actually can help increase the
number of women and underrepresented
minorities,
uh,
in,
who sort of make it through the
screening process.
Just to give you one sort of quick
anecdote about this,
uh,
there's a famous story about music
auditions in the 1970s where orchestras
had a very,
very tiny percentage of their members or
their,
uh,
their players.
They're the people who are playing in
the orchestra,
uh,
as women.
And what happened,
uh,
is at some point they decided to try to
break free from this and they will put
down a curtain between the performer and
the artist,
the auditioner and the judge judging
panel that was trying to determine
whether these people should be allowed
to play in the orchestra.
And when they did the results were night
and day.
There's a famous study of,
um,
that's up on,
uh,
the National Bureau of Economic
Research's websites,
uh,
published by two famous researchers from
Harvard talking about this.
It's called a orchestra in diversity.
And it talks about how the results were
night and day difference,
uh,
that women,
the fraction of women who made it past
the screening round shot up something
like seven fold,
uh,
between,
not having the curtain down and having a
curtain down and it just goes to sort of
show that's at this time there was an
implicit bias that women weren't really
the kind of caliber of musician that you
needed to be able to perform at a
Carnegie Hall.
Uh,
right.
at these kinds of top,
uh,
that's kind of top level,
some phonic performance.
And when you put down a curtain and you
just listened to them as opposed to
being able to see whether they were a
man or a woman,
uh,
you then without that kind of knowledge,
you suddenly were forced to make
judgments just based in the music,
just based on their ability.
And you saw that they w,
uh,
the,
that you are much more willing to let in
women than before.